he's the mayor of Los Angeles he's Eric
Garcetti and he joins us from Lima Peru
they made it official the IOC did by
handing the Olympic Olympics in 2024 to
Paris and 2028 to the city of Los
Angeles mayor thanks for joining us
how's morale so good to be with you it's
amazing
people are so pumped up u.s. I think has
bid more than any country and in Los
Angeles more than any city and after a
long drought the Summer Games are coming
back to America why did you want the
Olympics you know I grew up with the
Olympics in LA in 1984 I was a 13 year
old kid watched Carl Lewis and the 4 by
100 set a new world record kind of wants
the whole world come to my town and and
saw the very best of sports and it
stayed with me all these years so it was
the very first thing I did when I became
mayor 4 years ago was write a letter to
the United States Olympic Committee
saying we wanted to compete and it's
been a long journey but four years later
I hope I can pass on to my daughter what
my parents gave to me and seed a whole
new generation of American athletes who
are excited about being able to compete
on their home turf what did you learn
from 1984 that will help you this time
around in 2028
well the city ran really well like we
had no traffic so half the people come
up to me in LA can you get the Olympics
in 2028 so I can add 17 days with no
traffic in LA but you know we we took
the profits of that we saved the games
when it was on the ropes after Montreal
that city had gone into debt for years
and we made a few hundred million
dollars and we put that back into a
legacy which you know spent on like a
Tennis Center in Compton that helped the
Williams sisters be discovered
Russell Westbrook was part of a
basketball program that got funded from
el84 fund so I think a lot of Olympic
towns get it wrong and they want to
spend money on fancy trains and new
housing and all the things that you know
often are left either as empty and white
elephants afterwards or aren't really
about sports and in LA we don't have to
build anything new for the 2028 games
we've got it all in place so we can
spend that the profits we will make and
put it back into sports and I want to
make sports basically universally
for every kid in every neighborhood in
LA for the first time in any big city in
America what about public transportation
well we've got luckily not because of
the Olympics but our voters out here in
November passed something called measure
M it's a hundred and twenty billion
dollars to do fifteen new rapid transit
lines the most any city's ever done in
American history at the same time at
once so we will have a lot of things the
Olympics will benefit from but we're
building it for our city and allowing
the Olympics to benefit most cities get
it wrong and do it backwards build a
bunch of stuff for the Olympics and hope
that it serves the city but we thought
about our our own needs first and then
kind of fit the Olympics around that
instead of eyesore so yeah I think
that's the key though mayor because you
look at what happened in Rio you look at
what happened in Greece where you build
all of these buildings and then you look
at them now and there and disrepair to
be able to put them in play keep them in
play or just add to the infrastructure a
little bit just you know spruce them up
in 2028 I think that's really the key
because I I don't know how you feel but
I would love for the Olympics winter and
summer to almost have semi-permanent
homes where you could you could
alternate you know every four years
eight years ten years whatever it is but
you could have rotating sites instead of
putting the stress on some of these
other economies that can't handle it
your thoughts on them I think that's
such a smart idea and la I've always
said we'd be ready to throw the Olympics
literally in two months and we're ready
in two decades we're not building brand
new venues and then hoping that somebody
will use them we're actually asking you
know the Lakers and the Clippers and
we're the galaxy play can we just have
17 days a decade from now and so these
are active sports facilities that we
have you know I think cities are dumb to
plan something for 17 days and billions
of dollars and then wonder if there's a
future la would certainly be one of
those natural hubs if the Olympics ever
revolves to that of having you know a
handful of places around the world I
know
Salt Lake City is now looking at Denver
also but Salt Lake City has all these
existing lanes that have been
continuously used since the 2002 Winter
Games and so you know that is makes a
lot more sense and I think you'd bring a
lot of the global audience back that
right now in most cities who's saying
we'd love to watch the Olympics but
he'll know we're not going to host it in
our city he's
the mayor of Los Angeles Eric Garcetti
joining us Dan Patrick show how
important was it to have not one but two
football teams in in town oh well I'm a
Rams fan until the day I die so I was
excited to get the Rams and and the
charges aren't gravy and and my art goes
out to folks in San Diego because I
remember as a kid voters like to lose
not just one but two teams when the Rams
and Raiders left you know we always said
in LA the been astounded us more than we
needed them and we weren't going to be
one of those cities that subsidized the
stadium and that was a 20-year you know
stand off but ultimately I think people
came to their senses and realized we
love football were crazy mad football
town but we also were going to you know
wait and do it on our terms because we
got important priorities for our public
tax dollars but I'm so excited my wife's
from Indianapolis we were on the way to
to Lima for this vote so I missed the
game on Sunday live but I was doing a
little dance on my in-laws in
Indianapolis that the Rams aren't just
in LA they're actually winning now which
is great yeah I didn't think you needed
San Diego I hate I hated seeing the
Chargers relocate there but I understood
the Rams but I could you have done with
just the Rams in town would that have
been enough absolutely absolutely and I
said that at the time I said you know
it's great and both the Raiders and the
Chargers it would have been nice if they
could have you know stay put where they
are because Oakland and San Diego has
huge fan bases there's a big tradition
you know we lay some claims a lot of
Raiders fans and I'm glad that the
Chargers will build up a fan base and it
really is Southern California but you
know I believe in in players playing for
a long time on teams and teams staying
in a city for their lives that that's
really what makes it great growing up
you can root for the people and the
teams without wondering if it's just
going to be all about business and where
somebody can make a few hundred million
dollars more so what we embrace any team
that comes we're certainly happy to have
the Chargers in LA but I think we could
have been happy with just one - how long
does it take before somebody connects
the dots and realizes who your father
was in his role with the OJ Simpson
trial when they hear the name Garcetti
can you kind of seen people's minds sort
of clicking where you go okay
I know something's come up here well I
guess I get a couple of reactions
sometimes they say how's your brother
and I'm like and then it used to be oh
you're the son of gil garcetti and my
dad about a year or two ago said oh now
people come up and say oh you're Eric I
said he's dad so oh that's good you know
it happens to every dad and the
generation switch but I love my dad he
was amazing father is an amazing man and
yeah I think the Renaissance of the oj
stuff it was actually a good buddy of
mine whose brother made the ESPN series
and so he was reaching out and trying to
get an interview with my dad because
none of the other ones were falling in
place and i told him look it's been 20
years tell your side of the story and
the rest of the project kind of fell in
place so I'm glad he was able to get
that out there but you were in your
early 20s probably then when this
happened yep that's right yep
how do you process that link what are
your friends saying about you know how
did how did your dad know not get OJ and
Prisoner how did he walk free or yeah
I'm curious what happens when you're 20
years of age your friends can be pretty
honest with you well I was I was luckily
studying I was lucky enough to studies a
Rhodes Scholar I was in Oxford when most
of it went down so and even in Africa
doing some of the research for the the
academic work I was doing so I was about
as far away from from the action which
was a good peaceful place to be but we
all scratched our heads but my dad knew
you know Jimmy Carter was the first guy
who told my dad long before the jury
verdict came in he said look they are
not going to convict him and everybody
else was confident and looking back my
dad said Jimmy Carter was the one guy
who knew it just wasn't gonna happen but
you know justice came in a different way
and I think it's been a really great
lens for us to look at how far we've
come but still how far we have to go in
these kind of look backs at what we've
what we've done and where we've come
from his race in America still is a big
issue made a lot of progress but we
still have a lot a lot of way to go why
did Jimmy Carter think oj would walk he
just said that it was going to be
payback that there had been rightfully
so so much injustice in african-american
community that that a jury he told my
dad this was going to be payback it
wasn't about whether he was guilty or
not it was the symbolism and it was a
profound statement to come from a former
president who real
the pain of race relations the legacy of
slavery and justices visited upon
african-american men the criminal
justice system and OJ certainly wasn't
your typical American and you know he
was a celebrity a great athlete but it
was it was a symbol he said more than
looking just at the evidence good luck
with this and he got a lot of time but
boy you're gonna look up and you're
gonna go wait we only got four years to
go now we have two years to go now it's
here so but it feels like he got a great
game plan there Eric and we appreciate
you joining us we are excited and I'll
put you in contention on the torch
really I don't know if I can get you
know I don't want but we'll get you
we'll get you a leg in there okay now
how many people will be on the torch
relay because I just had my knee
replaced and I think by 2028 I'll be in
shape though yeah I mean it's like Luke
Skywalker you'll probably get an
artificial one by that okay but I'm
gonna pencil me in Paulie would you
write that down 2028 the torch run in
Los Angeles that the mayor even if it's
for a block though mayor you need to all
right I love that all right thank you
thank you Eric safe travels all right
that's the mayor of Los Angeles the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience